many people
dream of having the perfect body small
waist
a flat belly perky butt and a toned body
they think that by following the latest
diet and a trendy exercise regime
or the latest supplements they can look
like their favorite influencer or
celebrity
the truth is that the bodies we see on
social media
are more of a fantasy than reality being
heavily addicted and enhanced
the facts are that our bodies are
interdependent on our genetics
it's important to know that what we see
on social media
does not come close to representing the
diversity of bodies
that exist in real life our bodies come
in different shapes
frames and heights your body is
different from mine
and others i'm petite and i know the
fact that i can't change that
whether it's through my diet or even
exercise of course i wish i could grow a
few inches taller
but i know that my height has been
genetically pre-programmed
the same is true for your shape and
frame
some of you are born long and lean with
low body fat and muscles
some have an athletic shape and some are
curvier
with higher body fat that's because
we're not made from a factory mode
hence we're not supposed to have the
same
barbie bodies our bodies are all unique
and equally just as beautiful despite
all of our bodies being genetically
predefined to a certain extent
there are still lots you can do in terms
of lifestyle change
in order to improve the body you were
given and feel
amazing in it i wanted to understand my
body better
so i did my dna test with circle
dna one year ago and since then i've
adapted my diet
exercise and lifestyle according to my
genetics and my body has responded
really well circle dna is currently
the world's most comprehensive dna test
where you'll get over 500 reports from
diet and nutrition to fitness well-being
stress and sleep skin brain health
ancestry and even
cancer risks the accuracy is 99.9
the test is super convenient and simple
upon purchase
they will send you this at home testing
kit which
uses a simple cheek swap just like this
then place it in the tube and send it
back to them
once your dna result has been analyzed
your results will be delivered
through their mobile app which you can
access anytime
all you need is one test for a lifetime
because your genetics will not change
some of you might be wondering
why is it so important to find out
information about my genetics
by learning about your genetics you will
understand your own body better
and you will also be able to make
precise and informed decisions
about your health in the future perhaps
you might be wondering why does my body
react this way when i eat a certain food
or why am i not losing weight despite
eating healthy
by having information about your dna you
will stop
guessing and know exactly what you need
to eat for your body type
and the kind of training that suits you
better
go to circledna.com to find out more
about the different services they offer
you can use the coupon code joanna at
checkout to get
one kit for 35 off two to three kids for
40 percent off
and four or more kids for 50 off
this is applicable to any circle dna kit
you purchase and this offer is only
limited to the first
100 kids sold so do share this
information
with your family and friends right shall
we have a look at my test results and
some interesting facts
i've discovered about myself let's start
with body composition it says i've
increased lean mass body composition is
the percentage breakdown of fat
versus muscles based on my results i
have
a higher energy burn at rest if you fall
under
normal lean mass that could mean that
your metabolism is slower
and you will need to add more strength
training to your routine to increase
your lean muscle mass if you're under
high lean body mass you are more likely
to be on the slimmer side
and you will need to consume a lot more
calories compared
to the other body types to increase your
weight let's take a look at diet
my optimal diet type is healthy balance
i find this
really accurate as my body can tolerate
carbs and fats
for those who have a higher sensitivity
towards cups
they will find that they tend to have an
intense craving for starches and sweets
and they tend to gain weight easily and
their energy level tends to dip
after an hour of consuming cups by
knowing this result
you will be able to adjust your diet
according to your genetics
i will dive deeper into understanding
your diet based on your genes in my next
video
i have low appetite control this is so
me i'm always hungry even after eating a
proper meal
hence to make sure i don't overeat i
tend to eat in smaller portions
and add snacks in between my meals i
would also make sure that i don't store
junk food in my home otherwise you'll
see me constantly
looking in the fridge or the food
cupboard to see what else i can munch on
i have a higher caffeine sensitivity i
do experience
heart palpitations if i consume a large
amount of caffeine
and i can't drink coffee past 2 pm as i
will struggle to sleep later on in the
day
so i would make sure to limit my
caffeine intake to the morning
yes i am lactose intolerant if i consume
dairy i will feel extremely bloated i
will get cramps and sometimes
it could lead to diarrhea hence i would
swap
dairy milk for almond or soy milk in my
coffee
if sometimes i'm being stubborn and
consumed dairy
i will suffer the consequences later on
by
going to the toilet my waist
circumference
is likely average if you have a likely
larger waist circumference that means
you are more likely to stop body fat
around your belly either under the skin
or around the organs
too much belly fat can be dangerous to
your health
hence it's extremely important to stay
active and strengthen your core
i will be showing you how to do so in my
upcoming workout video
stress induced obesity for me my risk is
average
i think this result is extremely
important because some people
might have a higher percentage of fat
stored around their belly
despite exercising and eating well and
that's because
it's linked to stress-induced obesity
if you fall under high risk then you
will need to learn to manage your stress
levels in order to reduce
your body fat the app has some great
recommendations on how to reduce
stress-induced eating and better manage
your stress
levels persistent thinness i am less
likely thin if you fall under likely
thin
you struggle to gain weight no matter
how much you eat
these are typically your long and
lengthy looking models who can eat
whatever they want without gaining a
pound
so next time you're jealous of your
super thin
friend just understand that it's based
on their genetics and that
they on the other hand might wish they
had
your curves i have high endurance
capacity
now it makes sense why i can film talk
and do an intense workout
simultaneously without stopping that's
because my gin has a high endurance
capacity
and my body responds faster to high
endurance based workouts
i will also be sharing more about
exercising according to your genetics
in my next video i am a deep sleeper
yup once i'm in bed i will knock off
within 5 minutes or less and if you try
to wake me up
good luck i am very lucky to naturally
have a good
sleep but not everyone is the same some
people tend to be insomnic
based on their genetics in this case
it's even more important that you follow
a healthy diet
exercise regularly and keep your stress
level low
as lack of sleep is not only bad for
your mental well-being
but it also increases the risk of weight
gain
as for my sleep duration i need less
than seven
hours of sleep i think because i'm a
deep sleeper that's also the reason why
i need a shorter sleep duration
which is less than seven hours i'm lucky
my body doesn't need too much sleep to
fully recover
most people need seven to nine hours of
sleep at night
and some might need more than nine hours
to achieve
optimal performance and excel in their
day-to-day tasks
so even the duration of sleep you
need is based on your genes which is
something new i discovered
skin age younger
i do look young don't i that doesn't
mean that i should take this for granted
bad habits like smoking eating too much
junk food
will still have a negative impact on
your skin and overall well-being
no matter how good your jeans are they
shouldn't serve as an excuse
to live an unhealthy life and finally i
have a higher tendency of cellulite
formation
i find this information really useful
because i have cellulite especially on
the back of my thighs
no matter how much lower body workout i
do and even if i'm
leaner i will still see a little bit of
cellulite on the back of my thighs
and even my arms i used to be extremely
self-conscious and wouldn't wear shorts
but after understanding my genetics and
how my body is made
i learned to embrace it and accept the
fact that this
is my body i have cellulite and
it's okay no one is perfect and we
should learn to accept
ourselves and make the most out of these
wonderful bodies we are given
these are just a few interesting reports
i shared with you today
there are more than 500 reports to
discover about yourself
from the premium test if you don't fully
understand your results and want to
learn more about how to implement them
into your daily life routine circle dna
also offers
two free consultations with their
genetics-trained health coaches
and genetics counselors to guide you
through those free consultations
come along with the premium only
genetics play a huge part to our body
shapes
but that doesn't mean that you have to
blame it on your genes
and do nothing about it your lifestyle
choices
will still have the greatest impact on
how your body is today
and what it can evolve to tomorrow even
if you have
the best genes but you do not exercise
you have a poor diet and you're always
stressed out
then your health is going to suffer and
you will be out of shape however
even if you're not blessed with the best
jeans but you put in
that extra effort to exercise and eat
well you will be healthy and fit
remember this every body is different
and every body is beautiful to achieve
the perfect body is to first understand
your own body and work according to your
own body type it's not about following
or trying to be something
you're not so get your dna test
done go to circle dna.com and key in the
promo code joanna
to get up to 50 off links are in the
description box below
and in my upcoming videos i will be
talking more about finding
the diet according to your genes meal
suggestions as well as
the right workouts according to your
body type and i will see you next time
all the best
[Applause]
you